in 1954 Steve and Gayle Henson bought a
ranch in California called Sweetwater
ranch the area they loved the name not
so much so they changed it to Hidden
Valley Ranch I think you can guess where
this is going
Ranch Dressing is called Ranch Dressing
because it was made on a ranch so here's
the story it's a quickie Steve was
working in Alaska he had a crew and for
lunch he would whip up this buttermilk
dressing for them which they all loved
cut to 1954 we're back at Hidden Valley
Ranch Gail and Steve have opened their
ranch up to guests and at the end of the
day everyone would sit around and Steve
would serve his ranch dressing okay here
was the original recipe buttermilk Mayo
sour cream dried parsley dried onion
dried garlic salt and pepper and people
were all like oh my god you're rich
dressing so Steve and Gail started
selling it it began as mail order for 75
cents they would send a pack of the
flavoring and it took off in 1973 Clorox
came in and bought it for the big bucks
eight million of them and they begin
selling it as Hidden Valley Ranch
Dressing move up into the 90s and ranch
is being named the most popular dressing
in America and there it is ranch
dressing
it came from a ranch what do you know